i'm daniel de broken known as debbie i
am kind of engineering at artsy in new
york city next level of development
would be agile development in which we
ask ourselves what are we going to do
the next three weeks and this is how we
work today we plan three weeks worth of
features and priorities and so on and so
forth and then we stop every three weeks
we backtrack look at what we've
accomplished we'll look at everything
that's ahead of us we reprioritize and
then we go and do another three weeks
print when the team grew two maybe three
or four engineers we needed to do a
little bit of planning we couldn't be
walking on each other's shoes and we had
to make sure that there is somebody
working on feature a and somebody
working with it should be and maybe
somebody else doing some infrastructure
work that's when we started doing agile
development and Sprint's where we
planned for a week of work for the small
team then we realize that we could
really use a little bit more planning
and try and do too weak a two-week
iteration that worked even better but we
still felt a little bit short today we
do three weeks prints we do them as a
whole company not just engineering and
we were kind of like a metronome in
these three-wicket aerations where we
would start with a demo from a previous
sprint to the entire company and then a
will plan we'll figure out what we are
working on the next three weeks in terms
of high-level priorities we'll go back
to the drawing board rethinking some of
the features and then will iterate on
those and again download them three
weeks into this